oh [ __ ]
did you hear that hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
granny chapter 2 including Grampy hi
grandpa are you doing you look bad but
okay so if you remember granny granny is
game where grandma well not your grandma
or hopefully not your grandma kidnapped
you and then dragged her in your house
in you grab dragged you in her house and
then you had five nights to escape I
don't know why she was being so lenient
maybe in her old age she's gotten kinder
but it looks like it might be a bit more
problematic with Grampy in here so
alright tip be quiet granny hears
everything well that sounds familiar
grandpa doesn't hear very well but he
hits hard it really packs a wallop
Preston old the remove button to free
yourself from bear traps hide under beds
or in wardrobes you have five days heat
headphones for best experience
okay so this generally sounds pretty
familiar this is kind of what it was
before in terms of the premise I don't
know if the introduction is gonna be the
same but hey we're gonna find out day
one
oh so we're not even getting the
pretense that I was wandering around in
the woods I'm just in it oh okay well
this isn't gonna go well for me alright
here we go
mobile controls oh boy oh boy
I am wow I was so scared I okay this
time I be no [ __ ] baby alright come
along where yeah Grammy oh yeah
oh no this is gonna be a little
disorienting grab me wait
mmm what are you in oh-oh-oh
grandpa's what you see me why do you see
me go to hit me don't believe me please
grandpa grandpa why are you doing this
to me Oh God be able to beat this I'm
never gonna be able to beat this in my
life
does anybody know how to hack an iPad to
use a mouse and keyboard with it because
I'm not good with touch controls but
here we go
alright so observation number one
grandpa had grandpa had a key around
Grampy's neck so if I can just go yeah
that's not a good thing oh this is not
good
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay so does this does
this kademan
yeah okay that doesn't help me at all
that helps me none how does that help me
so I can trap one of them in there and
then killed dead is that there's some
gildo coming out of the wall over there
hello
I need a hand wheel I need a hand wheel
okay that makes sense
hey Kroeber okay Kroeber I hear what
well is it bad
okay it's not bad it's not bad it's not
bad at all extra is bad is bad
it's Grammy googa oh no no no no no no
no no no come on go go oh god I'm so
slow I'm so bad at the contributing okay
she didn't see me get in here
therefore how would she know that I was
here dancers what was that what was that
what was that okay sure
yeah a bear trap I remember that sound I
remember the sound of the bear traps
being laid down I remember it very
distinctly okay so if Grammy bear traps
is gonna be laying down bear traps it's
probably going up to patrol somewhere
else
oh no no [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no wait hang on
why is her an addict I thought I paid
money for this didn't I pay money for
this I have no idea all right so grandpa
can do the cha-cha slide under the bed
and it's really creepy I'm gonna try to
skedaddle out of here cuz there's got to
be it's gotta be a whole lot more house
what what what was that Grampy what was
that what was that what was that is
there something I need to worry about
oh crap okay well this ain't good um
okay crouch yeah that's helpful um okay
so if I go towards the tentacles will
something
I guess I'm in the water okay
of course the Sarlacc oh why do you have
an eye in your mouth all right so I'm
finding all the ways to die this is
great this is good this is knowledge
this is knowledge in my brain that I get
to have I don't know what I expected I
walked into the pit of the tentacle
vagina monster and I expected not to be
eaten alive I don't know why but I did
all right let's see what's upstairs if I
can get upstairs before they okay oh
[ __ ]
oh it's the house yeah I don't recognize
that but this is the house it's a little
bit it's a little bit different can i
play no I can't play it's a little bit
different but also okay okay that's not
good oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay open the oh
god touch controls huh closed door okay
I see your voice has gotten even better
than before grandma you're even more
beautiful sounding than you've ever been
a spark plug huh interesting
all right you better not come in here
I've got a spark plug lady I will plug
you and then spark you I will do a lot
to you that you don't want done did you
hear that oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] you what did
you hear
the safe okay last day good this is
going swimmingly guys this is going so
good I'm not a I'm not a hundred percent
sure if I would fair a lot better if I
had you know nice and keyboard I'm gonna
do my best here but you know you know
how this goes you know how it be you
know you know what's up okay so I don't
think there was anything of value down
by the dock it doesn't seem like that
big of a map to be perfectly honest it
doesn't seem that big unless there's
like an outside area that I haven't seen
which there might be all things
considered but for now seems relatively
okay okay let's see about getting the
items that I know exist
okay nevermind there's nothing in here
now all right good great there's gonna
be no Kroeber for me
get Grampy's coming down all I got to do
grandpa don't hear so good so long as I
don't insult Grampy everything will be
everything will be good did he go
downstairs or something I don't worry
[Music]
wow you're quiet you're spri for an old
man
so where are both of them cuz it doesn't
make a lot of sense that both of them
are wandering around this small area and
yet I've only seen them one at a time
each day okay so I just need to walk
quietly footsteps are the real deal here
okay so the front door upstairs there
I've got it upstairs okay okay so he's
upstairs now which means that I've got
free rein down here right [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
damn anybody in the shower can I hide in
the shower now you don't know you do not
the thing is that you do not you think
you do and yet you do not funnily enough
why am I here can I figure that out why
am I here I would like to know if that's
possible to know I love spending time
with you can I go back and see my
parents please anyway okay whoa what the
hell that's that's uncomfortable okay
but not untoward with oh okay all right
Grampy I grandpa you little scampi what
is that door lock door lock - what door
what door who can I get the gun oh is
this where the gun is oh [ __ ] no gun
okay I don't know what door this goes to
but there's got to be a door oh wait
maybe the front door maybe I'm an idiot
I need a crowbar okay um so everything's
randomly generated that's what I'm
understanding here I'm gonna put this in
here
so that I can oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
hey the spark Oh
damn you grandma granny damn you damn
you note granny no there's no need
Grampy no come on I've been a good boy
the crybaby please a [ __ ] I'm dead now
great
whatever alright um I'm gonna do easy
I'm gonna turn up the graphics I'm gonna
turn on darkness mode and we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna get this we're
gonna get this I just don't want
creaking floorboards cuz very
unpredictable and also I'm bad at this
game
alright we're trying it again I turn on
darker mode I don't know what that means
and also I turned up the graphics
quality because my iPad is like super
awesome something or other I don't know
it's probably as good as anything else
oh it is dark oh this sucks oh this was
a bad idea
oh there's the door lock oh this was a
bad idea
darker mode was AA darker mode was a
terrible idea I can't see anything
oh god you don't see anything I'm going
for the bad I'm going to bed grab crappy
I'm going to I'm in bad grandpa I'm in
bad you can't possibly get me
[Music]
[Music]
we're all laughing I'm laughing you're
laughing I wish I didn't turn darker
mode on you around the corner around the
corner engine okay I think he's upstairs
going around towards the bathroom up
there so I'm gonna try to sneak upstairs
right now I don't know what good it's
gonna do me but I'm going up I can't see
anything I didn't expect I'm gonna drop
this here that's not where I meant to
drop it but okay cuz Grandpa's hearing
ain't too good so I can kind of slam bam
II win bammy all over the place I just
got to pay attention to where he is oh I
hate these controls but I'm getting
better at it slowly but surely there
grandpa Grammy Grammy I grandma Grammy
yeah [ __ ] I'm running circles around
Grammy okay okay
upstairs they go stairs they go oh
what's up here what's up here nothing no
you don't know you don't know you don't
I'm going onto the bed hey you're real
low bed that I'm able to squeeze under
probably because you haven't fed me
I'm very malnourished skin and bones
let's just make some porridge
I don't know why there was only like to
go buzz there is this about I hide in
these oh I can I can okay I think I
could any other game too so I'm just
gonna wait for them to clear out from
upstairs okay that sounds pretty good
turn on mode stuck remote socks okay I
need a security key why do I need a
security oh [ __ ] what's that weapon grab
any key oh [ __ ] oh I'm gonna blast a
couple holes in Grampy oh I'm gonna what
is what is this all about
hello it's very clear oh [ __ ] that's not
good no no no no no no oh I'm going
under the table I can't get under the
table I'm fine I did it again I did it
again okay good thing they're deaf
you think they haven't got a clue where
I am or what I'm doing okay
oh [ __ ] oh no grandma please grandma
please granny listen granny granny we
can't aho God dark mode was a mistake
dark mode mode was a mistake okay bear
trap yeah that's not always the solution
to life's problems grandma
you can't just bear trap your way to
success grandma yeah whatever grandma
you're gonna get yours you're gonna get
a whole lot of years when I'm done with
you when I get this weapon key into
wherever the hell the weapons Locker is
safe key okay now I do know where the
safe is that is in the main floor little
closet I don't know what that means but
at least I know where it is right and
that is half the battle oh grandma
grandma no grandma no grandma no Emma no
grandma no grandma no listen he's just a
so weird object on the ground there
grandma
I don't know anything about that a
friend gave it to me I learned it from
watching you all right grandma you
weirdo you guys shuffling feet man look
at your cankles I didn't say anything
she just [ __ ] out a bear trap she just
gets their squats grunts OH and a bear
trap
pops out it ain't natural it ain't
natural I tell you that I'll tell you
what it sure as [ __ ] ain't natural all
right is there a way to disarm these I
forget
I don't know if I'm able to know I think
I just got him Oh Oh God no grandpa
don't do the cha-cha slide on me damn it
I damn it
ah the key I can't sing me it's dark I
need that key I really need the key I
needed that key that was gonna be ah
that was gonna be the recipe for success
okay all right I don't know what to do
about that uh what what was that who
opened the door where you want to run
that by me again
who's hungry are you hungry okay I'm
gonna go for the key again this is a
bold strategy that's definitely gonna
pay off all right yeah going right for
it it's definitely gonna work out what's
in here nothing great good the bed yeah
oh hi grandma
okay okay
she just shat out another bear trap but
it's okay it's okay
Yakub as I say it's okay and if I say
it's okay then volley wha it is okay
makes sense
good good let's go for this old
strategies the only way I'm gonna get
out of here because I'm definitely not
gonna get anywhere if I'm just
pussyfooting around so let's I thought I
could push you foot around you grandma
grandma I thought I could pussyfoot just
right through what this whole like
mobile game thing I wish it didn't exist
haha my bad my bad
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up Oh God oh I [ __ ]
everything oh how bad did I [ __ ] it how
did I [ __ ] it so badly okay we're fine
everything's good I don't know how I did
that oh god I'd knocked everything I'm
this is my iPad stand it's empty Perry a
box is my iPad Stan I am NOT a
professional in any way shape or form I
apologize for my existence I just wish I
want to get this safe open that if I can
get this safe open I will consider this
a job well done and if I can't I will
curse myself as a failure to the ends of
the earth because I will be a failure
my grandma my god my god grandma my god
I if I could if I had the agility of a
mouse and keyboard I might have got that
my god grandma you really really suck
okay last try I gotta get that key I got
it
old strategies here we go bold strategy
I'm just gonna go for it cuz I'm bold I
like my coffee bold I like I like the
bold air of morning dew on my my nips I
grab it grab it goddamn it grab okay old
old strategies get old rewards all right
oh I've got one more try okay all right
so I've got the key a little bit farther
I think it's to a place right now where
I could just go get it same bold
strategy as before get in that room and
then I'll be good to go as long as no
one gets in my way please tell me no
one's gonna get in my way please no one
get my grab it's so finicky to grab
theirs
I've got it okay close this door where'd
the door go door oh really are you know
like this you're gonna tease me you're
just gonna give me the spark plug that I
already knew I got oh you suck are you
sure
oh oh I really wish on I already did
this voluntarily you don't need to do
this you know Graeme Granby stop nodding
your head oh is this your pet okay don't
laugh at me Grampy Oh God
all right I'm going practice mode granny
and Grandpa are not at home I'm going
for cut I feel like I could accomplish
something guys I just want to feel like
I'm someone oh I want to wrap my head to
round like what you're supposed to do so
I'm just gonna frag this somehow I know
I'm gonna die anyway what is this oh the
security key the security ha oh not dark
mode really is way better okay this is
way better
okay so I got the secure taka okay so if
I take the secure taka what's in the
security room something there's nothing
secure at our room secure table buttons
oh oh we play a little five nights at
freddys here
oh so you could see where they are at
any whoa are you kidding me there oh my
god no
oh no no no no no no the wheel no no no
no no no no no no no no no no oh my god
no no this kid blanka's step there we go
return there I probably can move these
out of the way through my sheer body
mass alone if I crouch down and really
finagle it here we go that's easy
alright so that's how you open that
that'd be good to know cool cool cool
good good the door handle I don't know
god this game is oh look at door wheel
where are all these things when I was
running panics screaming through the
hallways all right I'm gonna tries one
more time I'm just gonna try this one
more time my dudes and my dudettes my
dudes and dudettes we're gonna go for
this one more time it and you're gonna
believe in me cuz I know I know now I
know without a shadow of a doubt where
some things are I've got this guy's I've
got this I may not have this but I'm I
might have something I need it crow do I
need a crowbar anyone need a crowbar oh
no no no no no no
you come down here god I swear to God I
swear to God that grandpa's silent is
the night yeah that's right
Oh what happened to booth I gotta shoot
you he's got the security key
he's got the security key that's what it
is that's the secret
he's got the security car so if I can
get the security car yeah you keep going
that way you stupid idiot you stupid
inbred swine okay so I just gotta I just
gotta plow through everything that's it
let me see if I can go upstairs and get
through the secret passage I don't know
how a game that looks this bad can
actually be scary that was what I said
about the first game is just like this
game looks like a pile of poop but it's
good right like it in some way isn't in
not every way it's not good in every way
but in some ways this game is I mean
it's good somehow I don't exactly know
how but okay where are you grinning oh
[ __ ]
oh that's granny oh god please Brandi
you don't make any noise when you creep
up on me crash okay day three day three
give it up for day three day three I
just want to get upstairs so I can get
to that little area oh no it's so
difficult now I'll probably cuz I'm
rushing like an idiot I think you're
supposed to play this game all patient
and quiet like but that's not how I roll
I'm brash on bold and God I'm handsome I
just can't play by the rules all right
if grandma is here
oh my god she's just there oh [ __ ] she's
in pursuit granny's in hot pursuit good
this is going great
this is going great guys this is going
great this is great is it going great
guys it's going real good it's going if
you guys knew how good this was going
you would lose your minds you would crap
your pants in a heartbeat in an instant
in an oh I thought this happened
well it's blocking the view there's no
way she can get me now she doesn't see
me therefore I am invisible I think it's
I think some of this [ __ ] strategy
would Hey Granby how you doing buddy why
isn't the head wobble so freakin wobbly
move I've got a crazy limp actually you
know what maybe I do because I I've been
I've been walloped on the head a few
times
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you come this way I should okay
you can't see me okay
where'd they go did they go downstairs
okay
okay it's my shot this is my shot
screwed it open and there we go come on
open up open up okay
oh man I got the Kroeber okay you know I
really took for granted the fact that I
got the crowbar right off the bat in the
last game much like the first one knows
well much like the first game this one
is heavily reliant on random chance
because everything seems to be
everywhere at any given moment for any
reason I just want to get this crowbar
downstairs and I want to try to on try
to I want to try a die I want to try to
shove it up my own ass oh good I get one
last day all right so I got to go get my
crowbar from the stairs I keep thinking
I have one less day than I actually do
for some reason I don't know why maybe
because I'm dumb and I can't count maybe
because I've been hit in the head too
many times with a bat and a bloody
crowbar that yeah all the blame that was
originally in my head is old splooge
'old out splooge down okay where is good
areas crowbar I wish everything wasn't
so hard to goddamn grab okay so there's
a box downstairs don't open that box see
what's inside what do we have a spark
plug I don't know what you do with a
spark plug but I'm thinking the way to
get out is either through the front door
or you fix up this little bow boy that's
not necessary boink that yeah
I'm not a hundred percent sure on how
engines work but I don't think you're
just going to the spark plug in the
middle of it and hope for the best
I think there might be a few other parts
to it but you know what do I know I'm
just a youtuber okay whoa whoa whoa well
well what was that all about grandma
grandma
you coming down here grandma you
wouldn't be coming down here well would
you have a reason to come down here for
you wouldn't that's what I'm assuming I
don't come down here my assumptions have
turned out oh I guess I'm dead
guess I'm dead and my dad proved me
right come on do it prove me am i dad
come on bruh me you prove me I prove you
and you prove me well it looks like I'm
not dead yet so there's that it's a bit
of good news I guess
great cool all right I'm gonna move on
now grandpa can you go away please
grandpa could you please just go away I
would love that so much grandpa Gramps
grandpa lamps ramble stamps up bees you
go okay up up and away
all right so tonight knock him out in
the back of the skull with this can I do
that oh [ __ ] where's grandpa
well Grampy was just here how are you
here Grammy Grammy
where's granpabbie lamps somebody call
an ambulance for grandpa lamps
he's about to get flame cold all right
so I needed a crowbar for something oh
that was probably loud okay that's all I
can do for now okay
oh hi grandma what was that of oh [ __ ]
grandma no wait listen let's rationalize
about the job I'm gonna run away from me
because I hate you I mean I love you
okay
go do odd weren't meant to be ladies and
gentlemen it's simply tweren't meant to
be
[Music]
how about for once grandma you shake
your head no and you let me live because
I've been such a good boy such a good
boy okay so I don't know if it's a
factor of mobile controls but something
tells me I'm not gonna be able to beat
this any time soon so maybe I'll
practice a bit more and I'll compact or
maybe I'll just wait until it comes out
on PC but this is granny chapter 2 if
you liked the heart-stopping action of
granny chapter 1 you will love granny
chapter 2 do yourself a slice of
something Grampy just grandpa doing the
cha-cha slide under the bed is just
gonna haunt my dreams for this in my
life
okay but that was granny chapter 2 if
you want to see granny chapter 1 I put a
link to that in the description below I
did a lot better than that one mostly
just because I was able to control the
mouse and that was important but thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know if I down in the comments below
and if you want to see more scare games
that I have done there are so many in
the description just click read more
down there or go in the does the
suggested videos over there thank you
everybody so much and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]